high school students using tick-tock or
instagram videos to land college
scholarships i know you do this all the
time
kirsten joyce looked into it they are
available and applicants are actually
using them to secure some real money
[Music]
seventeen-year-old molina wolf enjoyed
creating this instagram video for a
scholarship titled holiday fun it just
stood out to me and i was like i can do
something with this especially because
i'm from california
my mind went to winter and i was like
well california doesn't have winter but
it'd be really funny if i did like a
little pun on it as part of the
scholarships requirement she needed to
use hashtags and tag her top choice
university there are all kinds of fun
ways that you can get scholarships
jennifer fanetti of scholarship owl has
worked as an admissions advisor she says
while there are plenty of scholarships
that you have to write essays for and
are only for high achieving students not
all scholarships are designed that way
there are scholarships that don't even
ask you your gpa they don't ask your
test scores
you know they don't necessarily ask you
about your academic achievements at all
sometimes they just you know have a
theme that might be of interest to you
and there are scholarships out there
about texting and driving scholarships
talking about you know what kinds of
things you're interested in so there's
really something out there for everyone
no matter what your situation and plenty
of scholarships encourage applicants to
create social media posts they like to
look at scholarship applications that
are a little different a little more fun
a little more unique that uniqueness
allows students a chance to show a
different side of themselves omolina's
post earned her a distinction
scholarship to her top choice
and keeping with her creative fun theme
i made a little acceptance video
[Music]
tagging syracuse university in her tock
video
[Music]
sharing the exciting news with the world
[Music]
kirstjen joyce live local now